So we have this lovely equation, which is a great start, but it's still a pretty
general equation. Money spent over here, looks like just one lump sum. And
chances are, that Grant's not going to spend all of his money at one time. In
fact, it turns out that he's made a budget for himself, where he allows himself
to spend $100,000 every month. So this means that over time, as each month goes
by. The total amount of money that he spent will change. So this means that we
can rewrite money spent over here, in a different way, using this new
information. So, which of these choices do you think would be a new but accurate
way to write out the amount of money that Grant has spent total at any given
time?